okay i have received dozens
of emails and tweets and comments asking
me to weigh in about what's currently
happening with the online left
as many of you know i really don't watch
much online political media i limit
myself to the stuff i read
to be ready to do the show and then i
have other interests and limited time
each day but
i am sort of aware of a bunch of the
different things that have been going on
with the online left and i want to talk
about it a little bit because i do think
that it's actually
there's a lot to say here now as i
understand it there's a few different
controversies
happening right now i am very much aware
of young turks host jenk yuger and also
young turks host anna casparian
embroiled in again if i understand it
correctly it's a couple of different
controversies
one is specifically related to another
host named jimmy dore
and sexual harassment or harassment as
some like to say
and then another kind of more general
controversy is
between jenk and the young turks and a
sort of contingent of the authoritarian
revolutionary left that has a presence
online people like
glenn greenwald and others i'm not
exactly sure who else is part of this
and so
a few things are going on uh there and
then on the other hand it seems as
though there was
kind of a shakeup at the hills rising
and there are new hosts there
and that seems to be going pretty poorly
from the one one thing i read about it
and the question i've basically been
getting from people in the audience
is whether the online left is tearing
itself apart
in a way that is counterproductive to
the progressive movement
and whether the left has become overrun
with uh with with grifters
so let's take these questions one at a
time and and i want to say i was
actually just interviewed for a podcast
by cliff schechter and john aravosis
where we talk quite a bit about this and
we're going to publish this over the
weekend and um
we talk a lot about this issue if the
topic interests you
there's you know probably 20 minutes of
this stuff in that episode which we'll
publish to our youtube channel
so first of all the fact that there are
different views
on the quote left is not bad it's not a
source for concern
and it's always been my perspective that
diversity of opinion
is fine and good and should be applauded
and welcomed
what has been a concern for me has been
the increased gatekeeping
that i've seen some on the left engage
in which includes call outs about who
really is or isn't on the left i've
received many of those
as well as kind of shaming people for
views and generally unproductive insults
when somebody doesn't
line up 100 with your political
perspective generally speaking
diversity of opinion is good it's not a
problem in and of itself
what is a problem is when people start
to focus merely on calling out others
either for personal reasons or for
clicks or for money or to gatekeep
or to virtue signal or for whatever
reason they do it so i'm going to give
you an example
when jimmy dore has attacked me he did
on twitter during the election period
last year
i've mentioned my views differ from
jimmy dores but
i don't base my show and my identity
around calling out
people like jimmy dore with whom i have
differences of opinion
first of all it just seems so boring uh
secondly it's so childish
third what would i even get from doing
that it would probably be profitable and
i've jokingly talked with others about
who should i start a fake beef with
because it gets attention but it's just
not me it's not productive in any in any
real sense
now the issue of grifters is a
complicated one
and when i say grifter what i mean is
someone
is creating a persona and covering
stories
or taking positions or covering stories
in a way that doesn't represent who they
really are
either because they've decided i can
concoct this persona and appeal to a
certain audience
or it's going to be profitable in some
way i might get paid speaking gigs or
whatever the case may be now here's what
i can say about that
i'm going to give you a list of people
that i know are not
grifters and what i mean by that is
whether we agree or disagree
on any particular issue what you see
them say
publicly lines up completely with what
they say privately they are not playing
characters
they're not calculating their positions
for how it's going to be perceived by
their audiences or
for profitability and the reason i'm
able to give you this list
is because i know both these people's uh
public
work as well as knowing them privately
as individuals
and in no particular order here are
people that are not grifters
jenkin anna from the young turks i've
known them both for a long time
if you talk to them privately what they
say is exactly what they say on their
show
we don't have to agree about everything
surely i'd have differences with them
about for example the
israeli-palestinian conflict but
they are totally sincere in what they
say and what they believe would be best
for the world
i am totally sincere in what i say there
is no grift or calculation there
great okay sam cedar from the majority
report i've been to what must be at this
point 15 or 20 conferences with sam over
the years where we spend hours together
every political conversation i've had
with sam and that i've heard
and overheard sam have with other folks
including people from the revolutionary
left etc
the public sam and the private sam is
exactly the same person no grift
kyle kalinski i've hung out with kyle um
and i've talked to kyle a ton over the
years the kyle you see on his
youtube channel as far as i know and
again i don't watch a lot of this stuff
online
it's the same kyle that i know privately
farron cousins from ring of fire is the
same guy
politically privately as he is publicly
nomiki from the no mickey show i've
known her for probably a decade
private nomikee and public nomakee are
the same person
uh this is not someone who i guess we
traditionally consider to be on the left
and this
i don't know how my audience will react
to this joe rogan
whatever your problems are with the
things
rogan says and i recently did a video
where i said i disagree with what joe is
saying about vaccination i think he's
mistaken
uh there is no act there i can tell you
rogan
five minutes before the show starts and
an hour after and on the show it's the
it's the real rogan
okay now anybody outside of this list
some of them are grifters but many of
them i just don't know privately so i
can't really say i don't know well
enough to say
their public persona is different than
the person they are in private either
for profit or not
some i don't want to name names because
then i'm just engaging in the same stuff
but there are plenty of grifters
so then the question is is the grifting
going to tear the left apart but
probably not
um some people will make money and are
making money
um with the grifting with the calculated
fake personas
there are others who will then make
money from attacking the grifters
and on and on it's not really my thing
i don't think it's particularly good for
the progressive movement
to have people with retrograde
ideologies
passing themselves as being on the left
you know if you are an authoritarian
or a faux populist or you defend or
sympathize
the authoritarians or the faux populists
and the dictators and the strong men
i would question whether you're really
on the left
it's not a left i recognize but i don't
know that it's really going to
tear the left apart a lot of these
movements seem
way bigger if you look at twitter and
reddit and youtube
than they really are but it's going to
continue being profitable so it's going
to continue
that's basically my take and a lot of it
is very boring
a lot of it is extraordinarily childish
and
the unfortunate reality is that to some
degree we're all slightly narcissistic
and what i mean by that is anybody who
i mean okay if you're neurodivergent
then there this this may not apply okay
but
for for people who are you know not
autistic
and you decide i'm gonna have a show
where i give my opinion
there's some degree of narcissism there
there has to be because somewhere you
believe that
your opinion may be as opposed to
or different than millions and millions
and millions of people who
it never occurs to do a show your
opinion
is of some value entertainment or it's
something that other people would want
to listen to so
you're going to have a lot of
interesting and different personalities
in this space but within that there's a
huge huge spectrum
and by its nature you're going to get
this
this stuff within the space and i think
that
there are aspects of it that aren't good
for the progressive movement
but i don't think it's ultimately going
to be destructive
in in the way that some believe it's
going to be because much of the survival
of this very space the online left
depends on conflict and depends on
controversy and
so the the idea that it will become a
distraction from policy sure
but it's not going to destroy the space
overall we'll have more of this on our
instagram you can follow us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow and i'd
love to hear your thoughts as well
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
a subscription streaming service that
offers
thousands of documentaries from some of
the world's best filmmakers
including titles you can't find anywhere
else if you
are serious about watching documentaries
and you don't have curiosity stream
i don't even know what you're doing my
girlfriend and i
have not been able to get enough
curiosity stream
we can watch it on the tv smartphone
ipad
all of the devices they have
documentaries on politics history
science economics technology i recently
watched berlin 1945.
super interesting hopefully in advance
of being able to actually visit berlin
as things open up
really excellent film curiosity stream
is always adding new titles i have
definitely noticed a lot of great stuff
on curiosity stream that's not available
on netflix hulu or
amazon when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman you will get unlimited access to
the world's top documentaries and for my
viewers
because you're so great when you use the
promo code pacman
you'll get 25 off a subscription making
it only
14.99 a year